in a previous video we've looked at
these graphs this is y equal to one over
x squared this is y is equal to one over
x and we explored what's the limit as x
approaches zero in either of those
scenarios
and in this left scenario we saw as x
becomes less and less negative as
approaches 0
from the left hand side are the value of
1 over x squared is unbounded in the
positive direction and the same thing
happens as we approach x from the right
as we become less and less positive but
we are still positive
the value of one over x squared becomes
unbounded in the positive direction so
in that video we just said hey one could
say that this limit is unbounded but
what we're going to do in this video is
introduce new notation instead of just
saying it's unbounded we could say hey
from both the left and the right it
looks like we're going to positive
infinity so we can introduce this
notation of saying hey this is going to
infinity which you will sometimes see
use some people would call this
unbounded some people say it does not
exist because it's not approaching some
finite value while some people will use
this notation of the limit going to
infinity
but what about this scenario can we use
our new notation here
well when we approach zero from the left
it looks like we're unbounded in the
negative direction and when we approach
zero from the right we're unbounded in
the positive direction so
here you still could not say that the
limit is approaching infinity because
from the right it's approaching infinity
but from the left it's approaching
negative infinity so you would still say
that this does
not
exist
you could do one-sided limits here which
if you're not familiar with i encourage
you to review it on khan academy if you
said the limit of 1 over x as x
approaches 0 from the left-hand side
from values less than zero well then you
would look at this right over here and
say well look it looks like we're going
unbounded in the negative direction so
you would say this is equal to negative
infinity
and of course if you said the limit as x
approaches 0 from the right of 1 over x
well here you're unbounded in the
positive direction so that's going to be
equal to positive infinity
let's do an example problem from khan
academy based on this id and this
notation
so here it says
consider graphs a b and c the dashed
lines represent asymptotes
which of the graphs agree with this
statement that the limit as x approaches
1 of h of x is equal to infinity pause
this video and see if you can figure it
out
all right let's go through each of these
so we want to think about what happens
at x equals 1. so that's right over here
on graph a so as we approach x equals 1
so let me write this so the limit
let me do this for the different graphs
so for graph a the limit
as x approaches
1 from
the left that looks like it's unbounded
in the positive direction that equals
infinity
and the limit as x approaches 1 from the
right
well that looks like it's going to
negative infinity that equals negative
infinity and since these are going in
two different directions you wouldn't be
able to say that the limit as x
approaches 1 from both directions is
equal to infinity so i would rule this
one out
now let's look at choice b
what's the limit
as x approaches 1 from the left
and of course these are of of h of x
got to write that down so of h of x
right over here
well as we approach from the left we are
going to looks like we're going to
positive infinity
and it looks like the limit
of h of x as we approach
1 from the right is also going to
positive infinity and so since we're
approaching you could say the same
direction of infinity you could say this
for b so b meets the constraints but
let's just check c to make sure
well you can see very clearly x equals 1
that as we approach it from the left we
go to negative infinity and as we
approach from the right we go to
positive infinity so
this once again would not be approaching
the same infinity so you would rule this
one out as well